I have two daughters.
I know you have a son who's nine.
Yes.
We all sat and watched "The Willoughbys"
and I loved it so much.
You're the mom, Helga?
Yes, who loves to knit?
Probably more focused on her knitting than her mothering
which seems to be a trend in some of the roles I've played
but I assure you and everyone
that I'm not like that at home.
I'm a very full hands-on mom. (laughing)
Well, that was what was so interesting in the research.
You're such an involved mom, you love your son so much.
You make decisions about your work,
you put him first, your friendships are based a lot
in the development of your child.
And yeah, "The Willoughbys" goes there, like "Vacation,"
they don't hold back.
They don't hold back, but you know,
my son actually loved the movie
and I was a little unsure when we first watched it
and he thought it was hilarious.
I think he totally gets the heightened level
that my characters exist on.
And you could tell it's a movie that kids are gonna like
when my son watched it like four times through
and he doesn't do that for everything I'm in.
Like, some things he doesn't even want to come and watch
or doesn't really care but (chuckling)
which is probably right and appropriate.
My kids do the same with me.
Some of the things I do, they really like,
and some, it's not connecting yet.
I mean, it's a really nice sign
that he wanted to watch it
a few days in a row over and over again
even when I wasn't home or in the room
which is a nice thing to hear.
It's so well done.
It's on Netflix.
It's Maya Rudolph, Ricky Gervais, you, Will Forte.
It's such an extraordinary cast
and it's a really powerful movie.
I love the message that it gives in the end
that that love comes from the family you choose,
not necessarily the family you were given.
And I think that's a beautiful message
that we could use more than ever in our world.
It feels like a little indie
of an animated film really, to me,
cause it's very different tonally
than a lot of the big animated movies that you see.
But I think at the core, its message is so beautiful.
And I got to work with one of my comic heroes
very closely on this, which is Martin Short.
He plays the father.
And I feel like every moment that we shared in that movie
was inspired by him and his comedy and his daringness,
exactly what you're talking about,
his willing to go all the way in his comedy
with every choice and every line.
I think it's extremely elevated
and all families, like, if they haven't already seen it,
check it out, it's amazing.
Now, you're doing a reboot of "Name That Tune"
which is such an iconic show, on since 1952.
And I love how you had a quote saying that Broadway
was the heartbeat of New York City.
And that you're also getting to feel that
in the musicality of this show you're doing now.
Absolutely.
It was one of the reasons I really wanted to do this.
At first, I thought it would just be a lot of fun
and "Name That Tune" was a show that I watched growing up
in my childhood home
and would play along with my very musical family.
We'd all be yelling at the TV, trying to guess the song
in as few notes as we could against each other
as well as playing along with the contestants
which is something you can still do now.
No answers were ever shown during our games
so it's a really fun one that you could play along with.
But yeah, I was longing to be in a room
with live music and a live audience again,
and to feel that buzz that I really only get
from live experience
and especially from the Broadway theater.
And being New Yorkers, I have really come to feel
what a part of New York we're missing
by not having the Broadway lights on right now.
I really do feel that Broadway
not only brings obviously so much revenue to New York City
but I do feel like it's part of the heartbeat of New York.
And it's gonna be a little while till we're back
singing and dancing and hoofing our taps
on the stages of Broadway again.
But I just sort of can't wait
and my heart is really, at this moment, going out
to the entire community that makes a Broadway show.
It is such a collaboration,
every Broadway show that you work on,
and there are hundreds of people,
artisans, creators, people that make the shoes, the hats,
the choreography, the everything.
I mean, obviously I think you all know all of this,
but there are so many businesses
that are losing their studios
and artists that are really struggling right now
because the Broadway community is not up and running
and they are part of the collaboration
that makes a Broadway show.
Well, hopefully we're gonna be back there soon
and until then, you're gonna do this show.
(upbeat music)